I'm Billy Mitchell, Video Game Player of the Century.
I did the world's first perfect score on Pac-Man.
3,333,360.
It's exhausting to just say it.
You play 255 boards.
On 256, there's enough memory left in the game for the left half of the board,...
...and not the right half.
The right half is filled with computer garble,...
...anything and everything that is not Pac-Man,...
...different walls, different dots.
That's what a perfect score is.
The moment that score went up there, I thought, "Wow, I achieved perfection."
You get to the end, there's nothing to do but die.
There was nothing saying, "Congratulations."
There was nothing saying, "The end, game over."
Nothing.
The designer of Pac-Man, not only did he never think anyone would get to the end,...
...he didn't know where the end was.
He didn't know what point the game would run out of memory.
Everything to him is completely baffling.
They never saw the split screen until I sent it to them.
Masaya Nakamura who's the Godfather of Video Games,...
...he crowned me "Video Game Player of the Century" for that...
...and all the previous achievements.
It doesn't get any higher than that.